ever wondered how our brain creates our
thoughts emotions and memories well
let's take a journey into the mysteries
of the Mind think of your brain as a
super computer with billions of tiny
switches called neurons which coordinate
and work together to control each and
every aspect of your life from simple
things like walking to hearing to seeing
to complex things like solving math
equations and happiness but out mind is
not just the brain it's also awareness
of our thoughts and feelings but
we are and also the subconscious very
importantly that processes information
even when we are not aware of it such as
our heart beating and just simply
breathing so there you have it comment
down below and tell me what you guys
think of this the human mind is a
powerful and fascinating thing
consisting of the praying the conscious
and subconscious the more we understand
about it the closer we are to unlock
your full potential